nothing gets between walid ahmed ali and
the mangrove swamp
in the last 50 years kenya's lost about
half of its mangrove trees
waleed campaigns to protect them
most of them are found here on the
shores of the islands around the town of
lamu
where waleed says
this
is the latest threat they're facing a
nearby container port that the
government's building
it says it'll be good for economic
growth
walid says it's disastrous for the
mangroves this project it is not belong
to us it is belong to the few people
from the state they want to generate and
they want to make money for themselves
but if
the government they come destroy numbers
of hackers of land
without having the alternative that is
very
shameful
the mangroves and the unique ecosystems
they host are also threatened by growing
plastic pollution
and by loggers
the wood is used for fuel and the poles
for building roofs
across the channel fatma sells them on
the key side of lamu's old port
we asked her if her suppliers are
destroying the forests
here in la mo no we harvest and plant
others and we allow areas to regenerate
before harvesting again our forefathers
dependent on the mangrove trees we have
thrived along with the mangrove trees
over time and god willing even beyond
our lifetimes
the traditional methods of harvesting
the poles used to allow the forests to
regenerate at the same rate
these are the seedlings that grow on the
trees they fall off and can plant in the
ground or they can be planted by hand
like these ones here which were planted
a year ago they're about a meter tall
now for them to become fully mature like
these it takes about 10 years and that
only happens if nobody cuts them down
first
among these sawn off stumps are newly
planted seedlings part of the
regeneration program
when the tide goes out the planters move
in
mangrove can store up to 10 times as
much carbon as forests on land
western governments and other donors
have started paying for planting
programs like this one run by eden
reforestation projects
it also helps the fish populations that
many people here depend on to survive
the fish production is actually low it's
actually reduced
there's no crabs anymore so now they
know more of the benefit of this forest
once they conserve the fish production
infants
mangrove wood has been part of people's
lives here for centuries
for a long time its use was sustainable
it's too soon to tell if the replanting
programs will reverse the destruction
and whether the mangrove forests will
survive
malcolm webb al jazeera lamu kenya